[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
all right
i think we got it now
yeah
welcome to our workshop finally
interactive data visualizations with
maki i'm simon and
i'm doing this together with jewish
kombiger
what
are we talking about today
first of all we want to give a little
overview about what is maki for
everyone to be on the same page
then we have a little announcement
section
that we want to talk about
and then to
talk about what everyone is interested
the most it's time to first plot and how
to create a system image so we want to
start with that
then julius will give a little overview
over
how to get started with the docs and
look things up
and
after that we continue
giving an overview of our back ends and
showing some of the marquee building
blocks
and going one level up
showing the layouting system which is
built off out of these blocks and a bit
about sizes and units
and then i'll give a recipe example with
some interactions and julius will show
us a nice interactive app example
all right
what is marquee obviously a plotting
framework
it has extensive 2d and 3d capabilities
and is made for interactive workflows
it's hackable extensible and fast
at least that was always the goal
and it's 100 percent in julia
some people
have a bit about an argument about that
but i think the core of marquis is
pretty much 100 sure we are the back
ends
a bit less so but
to some extent
it's questionable yeah how far you
really can go to draw a pixel on the
screen in julia
um but i think it's in the
parts where it matters at zhuya and
hackable
and what was really important to me is
that the core building blocks are like a
backend independent drawing library
because with other plotting libraries i
made the experience that you can do
super nice plots with a high level api
but then you just want to add a draw an
error or something like that
um
and then suddenly it becomes really hard
to do that in that high level api so i
wanted to do it the other way around
that you add all these high level
plotting apis on top of a more simpler
api
yeah and then you have multiple backends
with different strengths you will show
that
and julia's created an amazing layouting
system for creative and polished figures
um yeah
now um we really want to thank um
our responses pumas and beacons buyer
signals who spent
um some money for this workshop
to help us work on it
um
which brings us to the whole funding
story of maki which i want to talk about
um first a bit of history so the mit
trier group paid me for several years to
work almost full time on maki and all
the ecosystem around it and gpu
computing
which was really amazing because
otherwise
writing such a large framework from
scratch would have been impossible
um
and since then
marquee has been mainly developed in our
free time
or on the side of some commercial
projects where it was like
um
10 to 20 were allowed to like fix bugs
or implement specific features that were
needed for some commercial projects or
the classic besides university i think
that's what julius did most of the time
during the phd and i really want to give
a shout out here to julius because
when i
started
accepting non-marquee jobs after the mit
time
i
really didn't have that much time
anymore from marquis development and
that's when jewish just popped up and
did so much amazing work on maki
polishing the documentation and
creating all the high-level apis that
make plotting really workable so
probably you could say do you save
marquee in that regard
and that brings us to the presence i
actually quit my job to
concentrate on working more on maki
julius works for pumas
now which
focus on maki projects
and we started tracking our time a bit
to see what does it actually take to
maintain maki
and we came to like one to three days
for each one of us so like
in an intense week that's maybe six days
of full development time just to keep
the project running
um
and if we are not doing that it seems
like that 10 to 20 prs are piling up
without review each week it becomes less
the longer it goes because then people
just stop
working on it but if we come back people
are really happy to actually contribute
when we actually review stuff and merge
stuff
and here big thanks to petro ferrig and
ancho who have been starting to do more
and more review work and
really um created amazing features and
of course all the other contributors
that we can't list here
um
yeah but this brings us to a large step
we want to join num focus to get some
more stable
funding for all this maintenance work
and maybe even put more time into
actually reaching out to people and
polishing
market's appearance
and write blog posts and stuff like that
to actually really actively
search for developers and users because
right now
it's kind of dreadful to get more users
because it means more work in our free
time but if we would actually have more
time it would be amazing to see market
grow even further
and that will mean gathering funds from
companies and professional market users
who actually use it in their
commercial day-to-day
enterprise and
i think it would be just fair to
um really get marquee developed there
and when we join num folks we hope also
for deeper integration into the whole
scientific computing world maybe there
will be a python wrapper or something
like that but
we shall see but i think um
yeah the julia community really deserves
a plotting library
with active well-funded developing
uh on it so i hope marky can become that
and of course we will get
more community events like makikon um if
we have more time for this
we are actually currently planning with
lazaro alonso to host our next monkeycon
at max blank institute so big shout out
to that and i really hope this will
happen
and i think it will be amazing to have
these kind of
events more regularly and more well
organized in the future
there was a just a brief question on the
pigeon hall what joining num focus means
can you maybe say something about that
again oh yeah
um
that means
that well
first of all we get more visibility i
guess in the whole community with the
big num folks logo and they do some
outreach and newsletters and stuff like
that
and also they organize funds so like
companies can
donate money with all the
tax exemptions etc and they will
make sure this all is legally correct
which we wouldn't be able to do right
now immediately ourselves so
yeah it will also be the way to actually
accept funds
in a legal way a sound way
okay
yeah so
that's also why we want to move to
makiorg uh originally um marky
has been grown in the julia plotz
github orc
which was great
and i've also been the admin there with
the goal that i oversee a larger portion
of the julia plot's ecosystem
but that was a bit unrealistic because
i never really had even enough time to
work on maki on all the things i want to
so
committing time to plots.jl or other
libraries and julia plots
didn't really happen
so i think moving to market work makes a
lot of sense also to just have
all the marquee developers only access
to marquee and not to plots or jl and
all these little things
also then we can have our own website
and stuff that like that more easily
with the github integration and maybe
even accept funds
for the github donations in the more
marquee focused way
the website so far only block.marky.org
is online
i think we will do the redirect for the
docs to docs.market.org very soon
and the other websites are just planned
right now so market.org will give
an overview over the whole ecosystem
beautiful marquee
is
will be the website that lazaro created
and awesome that marquee will just give
all
an overview over all the awesome
libraries created with
maki and or formaki
and yeah i hope this will
help concentrate on developing marquis
ecosystem
and while edit we also wanted to move
more of the chat conversation to discord
we thought a bit about it what would be
a good platform we experimented with
telegram
which didn't have any developer focus
features so that
didn't work out too well slack doesn't
have a history which is very annoying
when discussing something like makikon
or viscon
stuff like that because then everything
is just gone
um zulip is great too but i've never
really got fond of it every time i open
it
it just doesn't make that much sense to
me
and this chord is just seems really
great we have our marquee server with
our own channels it has thread support a
bit of syntax highlighting and really
easy ways to just like
work together and have voice chats
and
stuff like that so i hope
removing a few things to discord i don't
think we will force anyone to
to go there but
i want to move our the core maki
groups focus to do the communication we
have discord in the future
yes
this already brings us
to the big picture
of what is maki and
what are the basic building plots
um
so
maki the
very core building plots are just the
backend primitives
that each backend needs to be able to
draw
which is currently mesh line scatter
volume and text there are a few more
like line segments and surface
and stuff like that but they're more of
an optimization like surface could be
done with just a mesh plot
and that's actually how it's done in
webgl marquee for example
so these are more
the real core one even scatter could be
removed from here because it's also just
an optimization of just having a mesh
with some kind of
cut out or something like that
but yeah these are kind of the current
primitives and
if you're creating a recipe it's just a
matter of combining these primitives
and they're collected in
combined plot which just means combining
them
and it's recursive so you can call
recipes and recipes which then will
add
a combined plot to the of the combined
plot
and that's how you create more complex
visualizations with maki and all of this
is added to the scene
which is a bit like a
window abstraction
with a scene graph
and that all happens in marquee.jl is
completely backend independent
and is basically just a
description of what needs to be drawn
and then the back ends come in
and they create the actual pixel
representation or
in case of chiromarky also a vector
representation
so
just going through them webgl marquee
is for the use case if you want to show
a plot in a browser
and then it uses the browser's webgl api
to actually draw stuff on the screen
cairo marquee
is for more for publication ready
graphics
and its output format is svg or pdf so
vector graphics but also since cairo
just offers it you can create pngs with
it
it's not interactive because svgs or
pdfs aren't really interactive
but there's actually nothing stopping us
to just create a gtk
like window where you use chiromarc
inside to redraw every time something
changes but
since that's the use case for geomarky
which most people can just use instead
where you have a native window with all
the interactions and every all the
interactivity
this hasn't really been done yet so
karomaki is pretty much for static plots
and then there's a new back end it's
called rpr marquee which comes from
radeon prorender
um
which is a ray tracing renderer from amd
even though it's from amd it's
cross-platform because it's written in
opencl so it works also with nvidia
and it actually
renders the pixel to screen by ray
tracing which
enables you to create stunning graphics
but it's pretty experimental i don't
know i tried it out again some time ago
and i got a segfault so
needs more polish and as you can see
like the background is gray a bit
um
that's just because it needs a more
complex light setup to
um
create something good looking
so it's a bit different from the other
back ends and cairo marquee you can see
also that
the texture is a bit fuzzy that's
because 3d rendering for cairo is a bit
more
complicated so we pretty much had to
hack it in and then you get these kind
of differences between the back ends but
the goal is to make them as similar as
possible um if possible pixel perfect
output
and matching between the back ends
but
that requires more work to actually
achieve that
um
yeah so i i already mentioned the scene
where everything gets collected and
added to
um
it's
here's from the docs
there's a scene tutorial which explains
the how the scene works in more depth
but just a quick look at it to get an
idea of
what this contains
um it's pretty much just uh
holding a local theme that gets applied
to all the plot objects in that scene so
that's where the theming comes from
and the theme can get
set
um
globally
but that just means it gets added to
every scene you create
that's where it ends up in it also
manages the camera and projection and
transformation matrices so
that's where all the magic happens if
you
move around in a plot in
ngl marquee for example interactively
then
all these camera and projection
mattresses are transformed inside the
scene
and it defines the window bounds and for
sub scenes it's also
allows you to just inset them and make a
smaller window inside a smaller window
inside a smaller window
that's what shoes has been using for the
whole layouting system
to make that happen so that's also why
the layouting system is outside of all
these
more core abstractions
and yeah the scene holds a reference to
all window events so that's where you
need to go if you actually want to
create interactivity from window events
like the mouse events and stuff like
that
um yeah that's it
from
our slides
and i guess
that brings us to
the system image and how to build it
and that's actually very easy
um
i did a lot of work
on compile time latency for marquee and
um
with a community grant from num focus
and
that also meant adding a lot of
pre-compile statements to maki
which is actually great news for
creating system image because one of the
hard parts is usually
that you need to create a file that
traces
what you want to run
and from then from there actually
creates the system image with all the
functions compiled because if you don't
do that no function will get
pre-compiled and that means only the
using time will be reduced but not like
the time to first plot
but now that we added quite a lot of
pre-compiles to marquee
creating a system
image is as easy as just running this
command
and then if we actually
oh
yeah that's from the
um from the other vs code session
yeah maybe let's mention again that uh
that
the files that you're looking at um are
in this repository that you can clone
to
like some of the stuff that we will show
we will do
like while we are we are telling it
we'll do it on the fly but some of it um
is written down um
and all those files are in
the
dual con repository that we showed at
beginning and i posted the link into the
chat as well i can post it again
just so
everybody has a chance to see it
yeah
all right
so uh
as you can see this brings down the time
to first plot significantly actually it
was a bit faster than this 4.9 seconds
before i guess it's because all of the
streaming that happens now
um it's a bit slower but and this
includes
running julia with the big sis image so
yeah um i think that's a great
improvement
and it's not perfect yet i think we
could easily get under one second if we
add more pre-compiles
and more exhaustively and remove more
code
invalidation
but i think that's a pretty good start
yeah you can also
do the same with vs code
um which kind of automatically builds
your
[Music]
current active project
uh you just need to search for the
command runtil task
and then build custom system image which
does all of this very easily and
automatically
takes
around five minutes on a
faster pc
i've never tried it on a slow one so i
don't know might be quite a bit more
um
i won't run this now but
i already did that
on the other
vs code session to actually get these
speed ups and what's important for this
as well is need to actually go to the
to the juilliard settings
plugin settings
and activate that it uses the system
image that you created with the
build task
i don't know it's somewhere here
you can search at the top
um i think i'm almost there
yeah and someone on the pitch in the
hole this is some image yeah someone
asked if you can also load those into a
pluto notebook and
uh yes so i mean
pluto runs in the juria process right so
you can
however you load your julia process you
will run pluto inside that so if you run
the to your process with this image then
you have it in pluto as well
yeah
yeah so that should be easily possible
um
yeah we will put a bit more work into
this i think going forward but
yeah that's the current state and we i
think once the num fox grant is finished
the time to first plot should be 70
um less
so that's hopefully also a good
improvement for everyone
um
all right
back to the agenda
i guess we're now for two years and
layouts
um more like showing the dogs right
can you
give me a second
um
yeah i just wanted to say
before we dive into the
into the weeds um
that's the best way to get all the
information on how monkey works and so
on
um is
by visiting the docs and i just wanted
to show like the
main pages because maybe
it's a bit much on the first try
um
give me a second so now this whole thing
will
okay
yeah
infinite streams okay so yeah the um
our docs page is called machi.plots.org
and
the things that are most
important at first i would say
are
the tutorials if you are getting started
so
um we have one tutorial that shows like
the basic
the basic primitives
that you can use in machia so how like
the basic objects like the axis the plot
objects and so on how those work
i would recommend starting with that
um i wrote one tutorial on the advanced
layout
functionality that
is also pretty good if you want deeper
insight into the scenes but siemen will
talk about this more than uh the scene
tutorial is also good this one is pretty
specific
and
you will probably only need that later
once you've started getting more complex
with your plotting and then there is the
examples page and we've split that up
into
blocks and widgets and plotting
functions and if you want to know about
the
basic
plotting functions so what simon
mentioned or also called recipes um
those are here so you can see there's an
overview page with
a lot of example images for each type
and
as siemens said
all of those
uh plotting
recipes
build on some of the
uh
the primitives that he mentioned like
the lines or scatter or so on so for
example
a b lines with
is a recipe to draw a linear regression
kind of line through the scene that's
obviously based on the line primitive
arrows as line segments plus scatter
band is a polygon which itself is
really a wireframe plus a mesh
and so on and all of these we have
couple of examples that should get you
going relatively quickly
and
that will be probably the thing you
visit most in the docs
and the other part the example page is
the blocks and widgets page
and these objects are not
just plotting functions
like the recipes so there's a bit of a
semantic distinction i mean in the end
everything is kind of just plotting
functions bundled together yes but um
all the blocks
as they're called now since couple
versions
they have the ability to take part in
the layout functionality right so the
normal plotting
objects like a scatter or text or
whatever they wouldn't know how to
behave in in a layout
and for that we have these higher like
these meta
objects for example the most basic one
is the axis which you will use for
almost
all your 2d plotting and you can see on
this overview page there's like tons of
pictures there
and i will show a couple of these um a
couple of these later and also notes
that the
all of these
i would say the the focus of these two
sections is a little bit different
because
the
examples i mean it's called examples for
lack of a better name but if you can if
you look at like the list of stuff
that's written in this access chapter
like all this
there's a lot of information here which
goes like beyond just examples and also
explanation how things work and so on so
it really pays off to
just
like scroll through this
once in a while to
get a feel for what all the different
options are because
i get a lot of questions about um how
can you add i don't know second access
how can you set a subtitle and so on so
i think a lot of this clears itself up
if you just have a look at this
once
um so you kind of get an idea of what
features there are and so on
and for everything else you can of
course ask like on the
discord channel the new one or um i
actually prefer getting usage questions
on the disc
course so not discord but the scores
because um
it is kind of a service to the community
if
you ask your question in a venue that
makes the
answer
searchable and uh also that it will
persist there because uh i personally
and simon also like we asked
we respond to a lot of questions on
slack but anybody who used slack that
you slack will know that the
stuff that you write there disappears
after a while
and
yeah basically that's wasted effort so i
like going to the discourse
page to ask any kind of like question
that you can't find in the docs and
usually we transfer stuff that should go
into the docs there later
and
this way
people coming after you having the same
questions
can go there
and yeah there are already a lot of
questions there there's also some
activity on stack overflow but i
personally don't frequent that side so
if you want answers from me
i probably should go to the discourse
yeah all right
so yeah that's the basic thing i wanted
to show in the docs the rest so of
course there's like an api overview page
but that's really a ton of information
and you should probably just go there if
you look for
one specific function but you can get
the same information because those are
just the docs strings printed out for
all the objects that we have right
um so you can get the same thing by just
going into the normal
rebel help mode in in julia
there's more here for like completeness
sake and then there's the the news page
um which if you followed maki for a bit
i think in recent times we haven't
been that breaking in our releases
but
once in a while we reach a point where
an old design
pattern just
doesn't work that well anymore and we
want to make a change
and because we have the luxury of not
having like a
huge user base yet which would stream if
we made any changes so once in a while
we do
introduce breaking versions but usually
the way to update is really
simple so um
the first thing you could do if you find
like a new era and you you think like
some behavior changed you might just
look on the news page and usually we tag
these um
if we're diligent uh with like a
breaking
um notice
but yeah if you have a look through here
you will see that most of them are
actually pretty minor and we haven't
reworked like the uh um
the deep
basics in a while
so
because i guess that some people might
be worried about like if i use this
library will my code be obsolete soon
and so on and
i don't think uh
the basics of it will change that much
so like we have we want to do
back-end work
in the future
but we try to keep the surface api
mostly the same
because i think that's that works
relatively well right now
all right and then the documentation
section um
this
gives you yeah like deeper explanations
of certain topics uh so
yeah have a look at that at your at your
leisure um but i would say
the tutorials and the examples are like
the the thing to spend
most time on
all right um with that i think
we can go to the next thing
um
now we have the infinite screens again
let me just remove this phone
all right
um
and
let me just check if there's any
specific questions because i can't see
while i share the screen am i on a
different page i can't see everything at
the same time
all right so
right is there any marquee cheat sheet
available um
no not in this pdf form that you might
have seen for different um projects but
if anybody is motivated to do it um it
would probably be pretty great i think
blood circle might have done something
similar um as
someone says here 100 days of maki or
like beautiful marquee that's a really
great resource also for more examples
uh which you could check out
and
yeah the other question with like the
tight layout i'll get to that later
right
so
let's see
and the agenda
um yeah we wanted to talk about the
different back ends and monkeys building
blocks and with that
i'll give back
not to see
so
back ends and building blocks you
already did that
so i guess now it's layouts and sizes or
units
we skipped the docks
when i went to
talk about backhands and market building
blocks
sorry did you ask me something i'm
trying to get a get rid of this banner
made me aware of
not sure
um
[Music]
yeah so i think the next one is layouts
um and sizes and units
okay yeah then give me a give me a
second um
just to
just to get rid of the or can you try
getting rid of those can you display
i don't know who put it there
um there must be some options over here
all right but in the meantime i can go
to
there
is gone
yeah yeah it's done that's good
um
right
but yeah i think before yeah
okay um
i thought maki's building blocks was uh
also including like the figure and x and
stuff and i i'll show that first because
otherwise the rest
doesn't really make
sense i think
um okay so
let me go here
i'll add this to this pre stream again
[Music]
okay
i'll just reset this session so
okay this is in
vs code now
this should go away i hope
now i'll make the font a bit bigger is
that
easy to see i need to check with the
questions page
uh
yeah it looks
okayish for me
okay
all right so i i think i want to just
show off some of the basic building
blocks that you um
that you need when you draw something
with maki and um
then we'll go from there so this will be
pretty much on the fly because
uh okay let's first
i mean you can follow along with this in
your in your apple if you kind of have
the same versions it should all be the
same
um right so let's see yeah okay the
first thing you do is you um import some
back end um for example in this pa in
this case kairomaki cairo market only
does uh
static plots so no window will pop up
but i'm in
vs code here and vs code has this
plotting pane which is empty right now
but it's set up such that if you um
make like a a plot or maybe
i'll just do like a complete plot first
so some stuff will appear
i'll just do like i don't know lines
from 1 to 10 so this should
[Music]
hopefully
show up
okay
i think the other back end was still
activated so that's some of the
interesting thing with
yeah okay so what happened there was
that uh
through the system image gmaq was
already activated um
and now i changed it to chiromarky so
this activate command
changes the currently active backend
okay so like the anatomy of one of the
plots in marquee what's happening here
so um you can see in the plotting pane
that now we have this
line plot
from one to ten as i specified
and um yeah there are like different
options in in marquee how you can how
you can run plots they're kind of
similar to some of plots jls
capabilities so especially that you have
different signatures so for example you
can plot a function over some interval
or you can choose the interval with the
dot dot function and then it will
like try to
choose a better resolution for whatever
function you have there
um and i wanted to show like what the
basic building blocks of this are before
i go like to the layout
to the layout stuff so some of you might
have might already know about this and
some not so i think going at it more
basically
might be beneficial so the base object
as siemens said the base object actually
is called the scene
so i can do
i can make a scene and it's white so you
don't see anything here but i think i
can just go background color
as red yeah so now we made a red uh
scene
which appeared here and the scene itself
is
important to understand if you want to
hack on monkey plots but it's not
the
most user-facing object so everything
else that i'm going to show you is based
on this
like a scene containing plots
but um
i'm just telling you this so so you get
an idea of how these objects all stack
on top of each other and because
i think it's like a benefit of the
package that
um if you have some idea of the
underlying
logic that you can
go in and change things if
if the behavior is not exactly what you
need for a certain situation
right
so yeah the basic thing is like the
scene
and what we usually work with when we
plot something is not the scene but the
figure and again if i execute this
command then a white figure appears so
you don't see anything but i can
do kind of the same thing again
make like a tomato colored figure
and
i want to show something about this
figure so if i assign it to some
variable and i do like f
what is actually in there you can see
that there's a scene
and a layout
and so the scene if i show that then
exact same plot appears because
as i said so the scene is the underlying
thing and the figure is just a container
which helps
position um and keep track of objects
that are that we add to it so for
example like axes
and so the next step that you would do
if you
build like a figure from scratch as you
would add some
some object to it and i showed you on
the docs page before what these are and
one of them is called axis
and we have the syntax and marquee which
where you specify a location in a figure
by kind of indexing into it um so for
example first row first column
that is like a position in the in the
layout if execute just this then you get
an object called a grid position
and
these objects like axis and so on they
know what to do with this grid position
like to to put themselves there
if you um add them
so
for those who don't know if you do like
this double
pound sign thing in vs code then you can
run like the block of text between those
with option return so i just do that
here
for convenience so i don't have to mark
it all and
run it like that right so if i um
run this code then you get this axis um
which fills the whole figure kind of
and there are um
like attributes that you can set on
these objects
for example like
my axis as a title
and then you get
that showing
kind of a self-explanatory i think
and
again this axis object and i want to
also show that if i um say like x as x's
then
x itself has like every block it has
something called a block scene which is
the scene which contains all the
plotting objects and the scenes
the sub scenes that make up this axis
and you see that when i executed this i
mean she didn't see anything because it
was the same plot but here like 14 or 14
plots and if i run this again
and now it's 15 so basically the x
itself the x's um has its own scene
keeping track of for example like this
this stuff here that the axis
declaration so for example this is one
text plot and these three are one text
plot and there's lines for the grid
and so on so
because we said marquee is like hackable
and tweakable so you can always go in
and look at what these plot objects are
so for example i think if i do this xbox
in blockchain.plots then you can see
all this stuff that is already in there
like the text plots the line segments
and so on and you can in theory go in on
any of these and change stuff so i think
i mean i'll just try this randomly so if
i take like the second
second plot in there which is like a
line segments thing and i should be able
to set the color of that to red
and so if i show the figure now yeah
okay you can see that this was one of
the one of the grid lines which is red
now
um so that's
i think that is useful to know like that
the axis itself is just like a wrapper
around the scene and the scene creates
plots and so on and you can go in and
change everything you wonder about that
and
so what happens if you i showed you
first i showed you this lines command
right so lines is a function that makes
a
lines like
the the capitalized one is the um
the capitalized one is like the plot
type
and the
not capitalized function is the one that
you can usually use to plot stuff
um so you interface mostly with this
function but sometimes you also need the
type when you do like recipes or
if you have ever used algebra of
graphics is also wants you to pass this
but yeah these always go together like
the title case one and the other one
so if i run the lines function
um and again i'll do like one two ten
keep like doing the same plots
then you get this plot and as you know
we need like a figure
we need an axis and inside the axis
there are plot objects so
the object that is being returned from a
call like that is called figure axis
plot
and yeah that might be
like confusing to some but this actually
just like a three element
collection type which just says that
i mean if you want to plot a lines
function you will usually not want to
plot it and into some empty scene which
doesn't have any decorations any
any axes
markers and so on um
it used to be a little bit like that
some years ago but in the meantime
it changed and now every like common
plot contains like this figure which
then keeps track of the other stuff so
we want this call here to um
to actually show something right
so we overloaded this return type figure
axis plot so that it actually
shows the underlying scene and if you
plot something like this you can split
it up into the figure the axis and the
plot which in this case i'll just call l
for lines
so if you run that like nothing
like it's still the same output but um
we can check now that type of f this
figure and the type of
x's axis and the type of
l is this lines plot with a certain
signature
um
so yeah that's that's like the basics of
how you plot this is just like a
convenience
syntax right you could kind of do the
same
by
and like in the examples i sometimes go
this way sometimes go the other way
it's all kind of ad hoc
you can
go
like this make the axis and then you use
the different syntax which is
like which has this exclamation point if
you have used before you'll know that
this like usually a mutating
operation so you change some
object and you can pass the axes and
then you can do the same thing like one
to ten
and sign and then pass that back and if
we run that yeah exactly the same output
not surprisingly or maybe i'll just do a
cosine so you can see something changed
right um
so those are like the basic operations
and of course there are other objects
that you can use so for example and this
brings
us already to the to the layout
functionality and we want it in this
workshop to
go a bit
like deeper than the
than just the basics or at least give
you an understanding of these parts so
that you can hack around on it yourself
and
try to find out how all these different
parts
play together and so on so i can show
you something basic like i can just add
a color color by to this figure
and the same vein that i
set like first row first column for this
axis
i can go and say
like first row and second column for the
color bar
and this will just be like a
freestanding color bar because i didn't
tell it to
reflect any kind of plot that's that's
happening here so um
i think that's also a
uh
i would say like a philosophy point in
in marquee so maybe in other plotting
packages and maybe the best example is
probably just plots plots jl because in
plots
if you do any kind of line plot
that has changing color i think it will
automatically give you a color bar on
the side right
and in a lot of cases that is what you
want
and it's nice convenience and in maki
you usually have to
build that
yourself in two steps
but
like in my experience
people doing more complex um creative
kind of figures they sometimes want
uh a color bar that doesn't really refer
to like one specific plot object or it
might
have a multiple or maybe they just want
to show a color bar for any reason so
all of these are
really like separate objects um which
can be told about each other but as you
see i can just tool like a random
freestanding color bar in this in a
scene but usually um these things have
constructors such that if you do a line
and let's say the color of that okay
i'll i'll do one two ten so
uh so we actually know that there's ten
elements and then i can also do i think
colors color from one to ten it should
vary now
and then if i uh
pass l as the first argument
but the second after the position to
color bar then it should
yeah you can see now that the color bar
reflects what the
what the line plot was doing
so that's usually how it goes but you
can kind of
fake the same thing by
just saying uh i think it's like limits
1 to 10.
like you couldn't see the difference in
this plot right now the color bar
doesn't know anything about the lines
plot but
it still matches what what's going on
and i think that's like a common pattern
that sometimes you do need this manual
control and you do need to tell the
objects exactly like what you want them
to do
and you're supposed to be able to to do
that in
marquee
um right so
let's continue maybe by just putting
random
random different objects into the
into the figure just so you can see some
more of the syntax options
so one thing would be like a heat map
that you can do and there's a different
syntax where you
place the position in the figure as the
first argument to heat map and you don't
use the mutating function because it
will create a new axis
so let's say second row and across both
like all the columns that we have here
and i can just do like a
random
heat map like this
and maybe let's say a color map is like
each
and then you get like
as you can see like the heat map now
spans the first two columns kind of ends
here on the side where the inner part of
the color bar ends and on the left side
it's aligned with this
axis right here
and then
for good measure like we could do a bar
plot that goes from
like
goes along all the rows but
maybe the third column
so beyond what is already there
um and we just do
random values again
select this
and then yeah as you can see now there's
a bar plot on the right side spanning
those
those rows and columns
and
this is how you can build up like
a uh
an interactive
or like iteratively i mean not
interactive as
has said kylo markey is not attractive
but
that's how you can build up a scene and
i wanted to talk a little bit more about
like how this how these layouts work and
how you can treat them to
your liking and now that you've seen
like some basic objects here i'll
i think i had this over here in the
layouts script
right
so
yeah you can open that on your computers
as well
if you want
or just follow it here
and for this i can also
use geomarky again just so i can show
you some uh some stuff
in a and in an uh interactively changing
window so
using jmak is kind of like unneeded i
guess because of the
system image
um that has it baked in like on my site
but on your side if you don't have a
system image you would of course need to
run that
and it would
uh need some like time to first plot
which you don't really see here because
of the nice system image
then i do something which is like a
useful thing um if you have a smaller
screen i said though like there's a
function called set window config and
you can say float true
and then the
window that i show will just
always be visible even if i go back to
vs code because otherwise it's annoying
to
go back and forth on that so hopefully
i am because there
it was already visible in the background
so yeah this worked now i just restarted
it
um
so let's say that is like a window and i
already showed you the syntax um that
i'm going to use now so i'm just going
to place some boxes in this figure and
to show you like the the basics of
of the
uh of the layout so here the first box
is like uh first row first three columns
and as you can see it's across the whole
figure because
the figure the grid layout will kind of
increase its size if you put stuff in it
and that's just a convenience feature
it's not like an array where you can't
push things into out of bounds area and
it resize matlab kind of does it like
that but it's impractical for plotting
because you'd want to extend your plots
all the time
and
so they kind of grow with stuff that you
add and readjust
right so one thing i also wanted to show
was the layout inside the figure so
let's just say like f holds the figure
now right so if i go to the rebel and i
say f.layout
you can see that there's a grid layout
here which says it has
that's like the size of it in terms of
rows and columns so it has rows from one
to one so one row and three columns and
it has one child which is this box that
i just added which spans from
row one
to the three columns and so i'll add one
more box
in the second row
and you can see that it jumped such that
both boxes now take the
an equal amount of space here
and if i look at the layout again
then you can see now the layout has two
rows and three columns and it has two
children which are the two boxes and
this one i just added
in row two and columns one two three
okay
so another one and then
three vertical ones in the same
vein so yeah i wanted to show like this
this grid pattern because it will
soon tell you more about like how this
how these grid layouts work and when
what like the layout algorithm actually
does because if you want to
really manipulate your plots um
well and get exactly the result that you
need then it's nice to know about this
um
so yeah i'll add an access to this first
right
um
at position
one one
okay so there it goes and you can see
that
kind of the layout shifted again a
little bit to take in the the axis here
and i want to show like
if you look at where the the boundaries
of the the axis main part are like of
the rectangle then they match exactly
this
box that i placed there before like the
grid layout cell
as you can see right the the every
rectangle you see here that's like an
inner area
or
the inside of of a column and a row so
in this case like this first cell and
the axis decorations of this axis so
like the text here that is outside of
this this area in the default mode
and you can see also that the
the gap between two rows like row one is
here and row two is this one
and this space in between is the gap
and you can see that it's bigger than
the gap between
row 2 and
row 3 right
because there's stuff in it now like the
0 5 and 10
is sticking out into this
this gap space and this helps you to
basically keep things aligned however
you want them and at the same time avoid
overlaps because
the layout algorithm will push stuff
away
and it determines
based on the size inside the cell and
outside the cell like how the whole
thing should adjust
and let's say i'll add a second axis
across the first
two rows and in column two
and you can see that here so
again
if you look at the outside boundary then
here it kind of
is on the top and the right and the left
side of the this cell then it spans
across the gap
here right
and it again aligns itself with the
lower end of the
of the second row and here on the
columns
um
right so the size of the second axis is
like the or the height is the height of
the two rows
plus the gap between them
and as you can see it also
uh increased the the gap between the
first two columns now because again
there's like text here now and also the
gap between
the
two bottom rows has also increased to
contain these labels here
and the next thing i want to show is
what happens if you
uh
add something a different differently
sized object to it and
the thing about the color bar is that
it's usually quite narrow right and i
will place it
across all the rows that are here and
that's the the colon operator here
and in the third column so the color bar
will soon like take place across these
three cells and you will see what
happens with the layout when i do that
so you can see
that the third column completely
collapsed
to this tiny size of the color bar
and the other two axes have spent
outwards to cover the remaining space
and the reason is that
a grid layout has
different
modes i would say in which the
with with which the sizes of the columns
and the rows can be determined
and if i go
to the
the layout again
of the thing that we have now
you can see all the objects that i put
in are in this layout now and one um
thing about the layout is i think it's
called call sizes yeah
um right if you check out
it's kind of an internal thing but as i
said like um
i want to show a bit like how this works
so that you get like deeper knowledge of
the
of this engine and can use that to your
advantage so the the column sizes of
this layout are all
on set to auto
and that's like the most common mode
which just means
the layout will check if there are
objects in the column
that have a known width
and if there are any
or multiple then it will use the one
with the highest width and set itself to
that
and in this case like the first column
has only this axis and the boxes
but the boxes don't have a fixed size
they're kind of
they just adjust to whatever is there
and the x's are are made the same way by
default
same thing in the second column
but the color bar the color bar
tells
the layout that it has a certain width
at least in default
in the default style
and this means that the the third row
completely the third column completely
shrinks down and i think this is
confusing to some people who start out
with marquee because then
sometimes things shrink in their layouts
and compress down and they're like why
is this happening and so on it usually
just is because the the layout has an
auto size column or row and you put some
object in there which is of known size
and then it collapses
so
there are different ways to mitigate
that but usually it's behavior that you
want right because you don't want i can
show you a different way what could also
happen
um
because cb is the color bar i i save
that here and there's this attribute um
that all
objects that can be in the layout i have
and that's called the star width thing
um so tell with is like literally it
means does the object tell the grid
layout its width right and it's it's
meant in this way that the object can
know how large it is but it can like
choose not to take part in this auto
resizing of the layout and then if i set
her width to false and it's true by
default then you can see that the third
column kind of ignores that the color
bar has a certain width and it just says
like i don't know there's like
arbitrarily sized
content in here and now all the three
columns have the same inner width again
and the algorithm works such that the
the gaps between the columns they don't
count for like the
how much space a certain column gets so
the inner part
and inner parts of these three columns
they are all the same size even though
the gap between the first two is larger
so that's also something to keep in mind
that that's how the space is distributed
so let's set this back to tie with true
so that it snaps back because otherwise
that's just wasted space
and now i'll show an example of
like things shrinking
unexpectedly maybe um and how you can
mitigate that so there's this other
object called label which is just like a
block of text that you can place
wherever in your figures
and that's usually good to have like a
yeah a spanning label um
it's very useful for all kinds of
purposes so in this case i just make one
called label and put that in the
in
like basically the one after the end row
so this will increase the number of rows
in the in the layout and the second
column so below this cell there will be
a thing called label
right
so now the thing happened again right
that i told you before so
now the the grid layout goes in and says
like
what size objects are in column two and
it finds
only the label and the label says like
i'm this and that why it because
usually you don't want arbitrarily much
space for text right um it's nice that
the layout shrinks to contain it but in
this case
we don't want the column to be sized by
the label so what do we do we say like
with false
and then the column kind of ignores that
um
right and a different way you could do
this is um
like if i set this to true but i can go
in and say like the column size
of the
of the layout in column two should be um
should be auto
and then false and this means that it
will ignore stuff and this should
hopefully not crash
yeah so now it did kind of the same
thing but this will mean that the layout
will ignore all objects
that have known size so i don't know
that um might be useful in some cases
but usually like this default of auto
true is like the most meaningful and if
you just want one object that is being
ignored in terms of the layout then you
just set those tablet things to false
and then it snaps back
right and another thing
to know about this resizing logic is
that it only works for elements that
span only one column or row because
it would be
kind of ill-defined
if an object of known size spans
multiple columns or rows it it's not
clear exactly how the space should be
distributed
and so the
the choice that i made was just to not
resize columns or rows in that sense so
if you do a spanning label like this one
goes again in one row below the ones
that we already have but across all the
columns
so now nothing did collapse right
because even though the width of this
thing is known it's it doesn't belong to
like one specific column that could
adjust to it
so in this case you will not get this
you will not get this
behavior that everything jumps
and the same that i mentioned of course
also applies to rows right so we only
kind of i only showed columns so far but
you can see that the the vertical height
of the
like the height of the label here and
the label here
each of those has like its own row but
those rows obviously take less space
than the rows in which these axes are
so that's exactly the same mechanism
because the rows say oh yeah there's
this text in here that's this high and
that high and i will just um
adjust to that so i can exactly do the
same thing if i don't want that i can
say like l2
tail height is false this time height
not width
if i run that then you can see the last
row has now
expanded because the layout kind of
ignores that
there's an object with known size there
yeah you can just kind of have to figure
out for your plots like which behavior
you need one
sometimes it's this sometimes it's the
other and i cannot predict that so it
has some default which mostly makes
sense but
yeah if it doesn't do what you want you
just change it
right
so let's continue um with
one
more deeper example
um
so for example we can give this
um
oh yeah i see now a question coming in
on this big banner can you set all
labels to just be tell with false by
default
yes you can i mean we didn't talk talk
about theming at all so far but
let's just briefly interject that you
can
like for example uh
let's say with theme
and let's hope that this works now
uh
tell with this false so what i'm doing
here is like this with theme function it
runs one function um
while it changes the global theme and
there's a way to pass
options to these different kind of
objects that you can use and you the
keys for those are like the same
spelling as the constructor so i am
saying here that i want the default to
change for label such that width is
false
and i think
let's see
so like this and another one
uh in column
two
and another one and
row two right so the tail width is false
but the tail height is true so let's see
what happens here
um oh yeah i didn't return the figure
okay that's tiny
but let's say font size is 50
right so you can see the rows snap
together because the tail height is true
right so this is actually like a tiny
grid layout which just
shrunk into the middle of the figure
because there's too much space but you
can see that the columns they have
expanded so yeah that's the way you
would do it if you wanted to
and you can also make that
persistent by doing set theme
but that changes like your global theme
so um
depends on your use case whether you
want that but in this case i didn't
didn't want to manipulate the main theme
so with theme is a good function to
iteratively like work on a theme without
it bleeding into everything else that
you're doing
okay so i'll just
do this thing again
just hitting
on all these
things that i did
um so here's that figure again
with the label and we were yeah i wanted
to add a title to this axis
and
if i do that then you can see the layout
shift a little bit to keep this um
title in here and i think i don't know
like
yes matplotlib and co and
matlab as well and ggplot all those i
mean they all kind of do similar things
but
i don't know i mean i wrote this because
i was annoyed that i still had to fix
overlaps way too often and i think
probably for those who have plotted a
bit before they know this overlap issue
and at least with like these objects
color bar access and so on you will
usually not really get these problems
because
in most cases they are just handled by
this kind of algorithm and align issues
so yeah i mean you will
you can make up your own mind if that
that works for you but at least um
for me it works most of the time and
one caveat that is interesting and
sometimes people ask me about this is
that
the
extent of the
x labels
in y direction so how far down do these
labels here extend that is incorporated
into the layout but not how far a number
might stick out to the right here
and this is
the reasons for that are a little bit
more complicated but it's basically
that
the size of the
whatever size the layout tells this axis
to be horizontally it's not supposed to
change
how
far out things stick on the side and the
thing with these axis labels is that if
the size of the axis changes they move
as well and they might go further inward
or outward if the tick is not exactly on
the outside here
and so that would be like the cyclical
dependency um
and so it just ignores that and
sometimes this might
again cause overlaps so machi is not
completely free of overlaps i hope he's
selling it too
much but like in most cases it does and
if you get this kind of issue then you
can just increase a column gap a little
bit
to
get the behavior that you want but
this kind of tweaking is usually
luckily not required
because the defaults usually leave
enough space so in this case i wouldn't
even care right that it goes into here a
little bit there's space enough
so
um
the next thing
i wanted to show were the the different
align modes and that's
also like a deeper
you won't need this on like your first
plot but um yeah this workshop was a
little bit like going also into more
specifics i think
um
so i wanted to show this
because sometimes there's this problem
that
you want to align some object
like this axis you want to align it
differently so the default i can show
you like if we go x2 align mode and look
at this then you can see it's um it's
currently set to inside and what it
means is that
the inner part like the
the inner part of the axis maps onto
this
this area of the rows and columns and
the outer part of the axis which is like
the decorations they fall outside of
that into the gaps right and sometimes
you just don't want that for whatever
reason
[Music]
okay i hope you don't hear the i have
neighbors moving in and they have a
really loud uh drill so i hope it's not
horrible
right now
um all right so
yes um one good example of where you did
need a different align mode is already
happening in front of our eyes but it's
not
obvious from just looking at it but the
main grid layout of the figure it has a
different align mode because if i place
stuff such that it aligned with the
inner part then all the axis decorations
here they would bleed out of the of the
figure right
i mean think about if this axis would
map right to the edge of the screen with
its inner part then the 10 would fall
outside of the
and the five and the zero they would
fall outside i mean i can kind of show
that i think
if i said if i take the um
the figure layout yes and i look at that
one's align mode you can see okay it's
kind of messy to print out but yeah it
has an outside alignment with like a
padding of 16 applied in every dimension
um and if i if i change that to inside
which i can
then
okay oh yeah okay now i did this thing
where
that was a good example i think i just
replaced the
the observable
um
let me just see if i did or not
okay yeah i didn't it just not hooked up
the the way i thought but that doesn't
matter because usually you don't do it
like this like you set it up in the
beginning but now i set the alignment to
inside and you see all the decorations
they popped out of the figure because
now the inner parts of every element
kind of go right to the edge
and i mean that's usually not what you
want right so
so that's why the default is like
outside and let's say again 16 like it
was before and
i'll call this internal update function
again
right so now everything is back inside
again and i'll show the same thing with
this axis here with the big axis let's
say i didn't really want
this line of the axis to align with that
line of the other axis but i somehow
want the top part of the title to align
with this and i want
i want these tick labels to go inside
and these also then i can change the
alignment to outside
right so you see now this thing is now
contained inside this
rectangle except for the zero of the 10
which i talked about before right that's
the thing going to the side that doesn't
kind of count
but here the thing
just is like moved into into this
rectangle and sometimes that that's
exactly what you need for a certain plot
so it's nice to nice to have seen it
before i think
and i can change it back to inside now
it's as it was before and there's also
like an even more
specialized case um in some cases you
want one part of the
of the outside i i call those like the
protrusions because they like protrude
from the main part
sometimes you just want one part of
those two to move inwards
and so you can go and say align mode
mixed bottom zero and now it applies
like a padding of zero while
taking the bottom part into the into the
space
we can do something similar with like
bottom zero on top thirty so this time
the title will move inwards and get an
additional padding of 30
this
so you can see there's no gap and that's
kind of the same thing that figure
itself does right so the outer padding
as i told you before that's that comes
from this alignment and another thing i
mean i showed i showed the call size
command but like there's also the column
gap command which you can apply on the
layout so in this case we want to set
the first column gap to like 80 units
and then the thing spans out so if if
there's really like too much going on
here and these things fight with each
other or overlap then you can set that
as large as you want
um
right that's what i wanted to show about
this and the other thing
okay i haven't really looked at
questions in a while i'll look soon
after i do the next example if there's
anything i should cover
so the next thing i wanted to show
because it always crops up like people
want to plot
plots with certain fixed aspect ratios
all the time and what they usually do is
um
they find
the aspect
attribute of axis
and they know from other plotting
software that that's what you usually do
like you you take the axis and you say
you are now a square axis
and what that looks like
fb
like this figure
and put
i have some setup code here
but
okay maybe
um
that's fine i'll do the whole thing i
think i think it's fine so what i'm
doing here is to demonstrate um i'm i'm
doing two separate grid layouts that are
nested inside the grid layout that i
have so one is in the first row the
first column the others in the second
row the first column right gl1 and gr2
and i can place an axis
placed in the subgrid layout
and i give it aspect as one and i place
a box next to it and so now the box
has one of the columns in the first grid
layout which spans this first row
and the axis has the other column
and you can already see that the axis is
square but there's like white space here
and white space there
and so now i'm putting stuff in the
second grid layout which is currently
empty
i'm putting in an axis again at
row one column one
um which spans like the whole nested
grid layout in the lower row and i place
another box here
so now this the default thing where no
aspects are set
and now you can see the box has the same
inner size as the axis but we want the
axis squared right so
what we can do is on the layout level we
can say
we need the
the first column
which now has an auto size i showed you
before um we needed to have an aspect
size and aspect means that the layout
algorithm that kind of computes all the
other columns that it can and then it
tries to match the size of a column or a
row
to
an opposite
column or row with an aspect applied so
if we set the column size of the first
column in this sub layout here
to aspect 1
and 1.0
i wrote this as a float so you can see
it's different things so the first one
refers to
which index of the opposite side you're
talking about right so in this case this
lower grid layout just has one row so
obviously we can only specify an
aspect versus this first row
and the aspect that i want is 1.0 so
that means
this first column will wait and see what
the row sizes on the other
side are
and then when it knows what the row one
has for size then it will adjust itself
to be aspect one relative to that and if
i do this then now you can see the box
filled the remaining space
because it has an auto sized column and
just waits what space is available and
then it just fills itself and into that
but the axis is
square
and the layout is kind of
correctly filled with this information
and i can show you now what happens if i
adjust this figure like
for different figure sizes right you
could be lucky and have a figure size
like this and it wouldn't make a
difference like you wouldn't even see
that the two are different but if it's
like white you can see the top has a lot
of wasted space
because
what the axis is actually doing is it
just it it tells the layout i don't have
a specific size so it gets like this big
rectangle to work with and then it just
goes in itself and says like ah actually
i want to be aspects uh aspect of one
and then the rest of space is kind of
lost where in this other case the layout
knows that the first column and the
first row have this best specific
relationship
and then
that's a really common thing you want to
do in your plots if you have aspect
sizes
and obviously
uh you cannot put in too many of these
aspect constraints right because let's
say i also wanted the the box here to be
aspect size but i don't want a asp like
a square aspect but i don't want any any
space to be lost
that's kind of impossible
because
you cannot put two squares next to each
other in this space and expect
it all to fit
right so
that's one really important thing that
that you should have seen
and the last thing i want to show is
like why not do this with the row size
and um
let's just do this example again up to
the point where
the column size and if i said to the
layout just make the row
the first row
with an aspect of one
to the first column
then
the algorithm would go like okay what
are the column sizes this one is that
big and this one is that big and then it
goes say okay the first row is now one
relative to the other one and you can
see that this doesn't fit right
it doesn't make sense at least
um
so the order matters um
because the algorithm really waits to
see what sizes other things have and
if um
in this case the columns just already
take the space that they want then this
messes things up so often you will just
want to check what you did here
all right yeah that's what i want to
show and i'll give back to simon who
will go over recipes
all right um but now you should have a
break first
oh yeah good point
i mean we did start later so i wonder i
mean we can see how far we get um
but yeah
you should like how much break you want
to take
five minutes five minutes okay
yeah now let's be back at
you know sam yeah
17 47 or whatever donate that
yeah
okay all right um
all right welcome back
i guess we start by
answering the last unanswered question
i guess
that's yeah my collection just
broke a bit i wonder why
uh
okay can you hear me now
good
all right uh i'll just quickly share the
screen again like how can you put a box
inside a box that you actually want to
overlap i can only try to interpret what
that uh
what that really
means but i imagine you want to see
something like this
uh
okay again like that
okay so let's say you want
uh
okay you have a figure and we put a box
across this whole thing
that's just like in the first cell and
we say its color is
gray
50 or whatever
so let's see how that looks okay so
that's like a box and
i say now overlap that to me it says
like you want like another box that's
kind of inside here
um if not then
sorry
but i would do it like this um
because we want like a padding towards
the boundary of this box i just say like
okay let's put another grid layout in
here
um
and this grid layout
has align mode outside so it kind of
keeps padding towards the outside and we
just give it some padding value let's
say like 20
and the way you put that
wait i think we can actually do like
this now
um
let's see
right so that doesn't make any visual
difference but now there's this grid
layout here and if i place further stuff
into that then
um
oh now we put that into the grid layout
right at position one one and now we say
colors tomato i really love the tomato
color for some reason
uh yeah there's
there's the box inside the box
overlapping it with like padding and now
i could do
like more boxes
like that
uh
color green like this
right so if you wanted to do like a
figure where you place stuff
um in different boxes and uh want to
highlight it this way then that's how i
would do it
all right
back to simon
alright
let's
talk about recipes
um
here we go so recipes in maki have kind
of an interesting history
compared
to plots.jl because
um i always thought about them in a very
low level way and
just to build up basic new graphic types
and they're still kind of that way
which made it a bit hard to make these
kind of high level um
recipes with the whole layouting system
and everything
but yeah um i'll just show you how to
write
your first simple
recipe i'm going to show how to
make a little graph plot recipe
where you just pass vertices and
connection
and the syntax here
has multiple parts so that's the name
of the plot object and the lowercase
version
of that will be the function name you
can call to directly call into this
these ones are the argument names
of this plotting
object
and then you have this do block with the
scene the scene is just a convenience
because sometimes you may want to access
them to
eg
inherit from from the scene theme so you
can do something like
this to get like the current um color
from the current scene
theme
um
[Music]
but yeah these are the
keyword arguments and if we look
at what this macro actually expands to
we
i wrote this out here it's heavily
reduced pseudocode because it's a bit
more complex than this with all the
observable things but
in simple terms it just defines this
graphplot function which then gets used
to create this combined
plot type
with the graphplot function as a
argument so that you can differentiate
it and dispatch on it
and that becomes an alias to make it
more easy
to actually work with it
and then this
attributes thing here
um ends up in the default theme function
and gets returned
and invoked then with the current scene
that
the plot object gets plotted to
and then we have this main important
overload which is the one that's most
heavily simplified because
there's quite a
complex plotting pipeline to make to
enable that you can pass a figure can
pass a axis and a scene and all these
kind of things
and then also make it work with
observables
but in simple terms it looks like that
in the end if you call graphplot
first
the
positional arguments get converted and
passed to convert arguments
then
the theme is applied from the default
theme to the keyword arguments
and this then gets passed to the
graphplot
plot object
and this creates
this object
and
that way the plot object already exists
before actually going into your recipe
code which happens then here in this
overload
where you can add new
like
plotting functions in there and then it
just gets pushed to the
figure like which then in the end is
usually the scene because the x's
themselves don't really hold this
so
yeah to actually overload the recipe we
need to overload this function as
pointed out before
here we have then the argument names we
can directly access from from these here
so we have vertices and connections
and likewise you can also access the
attributes like that sub vertex color
and connection color in this case
and when we execute that
we should be able to get our first
recipe going
um
so let's try our first
one
just pass the color down so we have them
all stored in the spot object and this
might be a bit weird but you basically
use the existing plot object instead of
a scene and just plot into this and that
way you get this kind of combined plot
and if we try this out
with some
data i prepared
we can see that we
get the circle as a nice scatter plot so
far
and then for graph plot
we also want to
have the connections
and
yeah i
already
prepared this in the finished app
so that
we access the connection one which is
just like an array
of tuples so um
which defines the segments that should
be connected
um
[Music]
and
those all of these attributes here are
now observables regardless of what you
actually pass to the functions
that's what makes the recipes a bit
harder to work with than for example in
plots.jl
because it could always just change
and
but it also makes it as a default that
you can interact with these kind of new
recipes
and plot the types
and then
yeah so we just go through all the
connections
push the points in here and then
actually
draw them with the line segments
but
so if we do that
we should get
the connections as well
and
not to forget we actually defined a
color here as well so we can pass that
down as well
to actually get
get this grayish color here as a default
um
i guess there are no questions good
yes that's a very um
basic recipe to get you started
and then
a lot of people have the difficulties
what's like what's done in convert
arguments and what's done in this kind
of recipe code i think
the recipe is when you want to have a
lot of control over all these
observables here and want to update them
separately for performance reasons
because in convert arguments everything
gets updated the same time so
if any of the arguments changes the
whole function gets run again and again
and here it's really
fine grained
but one good use case for convert
arguments here is if we actually wanted
to make a
turn this into a
bit more nicer high level
um graph recipe that
actually
accepts a graph from grass.jl
and then we also need network layout
because graphs need to have some kind of
2d layout to plot them actually
and
to keep it simple
we just find all the connections in the
adjacent adjacency matrix
then for now we just hard code a layout
algorithm that we are using and that
spits out
an array of points
which we then can pass
basically to the recipe so what you
return here
will end up in
in these
arguments here as you can see here so
that's pretty much then what ends up in
the plot object
so if we define this
um
we can then just pass
any
of the pre-made graphs
um
objects in here
and ta-da we
can see the wheel graph from gras.jl in
here
um this is all interactive as i said so
we can actually take a look at this plot
object
so that's this combined object here that
i talked about and you can access
all these
attributes here so you can change the
vertex color to blue for example
and
you could also
look at
this here because that's just the array
that holds the subplots in there
and
it's a bit hacky but you could also then
just go in here
and
go into the scatter plots and for
example change the marker size
immediately so
yeah this is all interactive you can
also
access the arguments by
by their position so one was our
vertices i know in this case now it's
from
from the convert arguments it's just the
graph so we can actually give it a
different graph for example one with
more vertices
and
then update that now we don't see
anything that because the limit changed
and with a double click or with reset
limits
um we then just see the updated plot so
that's a very easy way to already
animate and
interact with this
new recipe
we have and
yeah um
from there we can try to see
how to interact with this graph plot
i
want to make a
one where you can just drag around these
vertices here
so right now there's another interaction
registered there
which is the zoom rectangle
from the axis which you would need to
disable first
this can be done with um
de-register or deactivate an interaction
right now i'll just de-register it
completely the rectangle zoom
and
now
we don't zoom in anymore if we track
so like this we can actually start
adding a new interaction
how to do this
let's first of all look at the main
api for this
which is at mouse events
um
it can be added to any scene and then we
get this handle back
here so for example if we go into the x
dot scene
which is um the scene
in the middle here we can just display
it for a second to see what actually
shows
ah that displays in vs code so
that's just the main
um window without the access decorations
and if we add mouse interactions to the
scene
we get this event here
this handle
which has
is this field here which is an
observable that you can register
function callbacks on which works with
the on function so you can do something
like this on event
and then show event
and now i
need the terminal
uh
here it is
and now we get all these mouse events
here spit out
um
can also
like this
um
i need to
keep
[Music]
two ends
and then we can look at it
so the data is
just a point in data coordinates so if
i'm here it should correspond to this
point in data coordinates
and which means all the transformations
from the scene and axis are applied to
it
there's also a corresponding one
with
in pixel coordinates so that's then in
the window coordinates of this
so if we actually want to
um draw these
the data one is very easy that's the one
you would actually
draw to the
axis itself
so let's start
with an
empty observable
scatter that to the x
and then now on mouse events
we can just
update this observable
with the new data
[Music]
in the first
place or we could actually just replace
the whole array well this is easier
and
then we should see that there's now a
point following our mouse in these data
coordinates
if you want to actually plot the do the
same
for the pixel coordinates
you would need like
um
you would need to draw it in in pixel
coordinates which can be done for
example with creating a sub scene with
only a pixel camera
applied as a transformation
which
there is a
convenience constructor for that
um
and pixel is called and without the bang
it returns a new scene
if you plot to this
um
you will need to
plot the pixel coordinates so i'll just
give you an example
pixel scene
and then
this
there we go then you would go from pixel
0 to 500 here
um
i should disable the propane
and that means
if we do the same here
then this time plug this observer to the
pixel scene
and we can
actually use the fixed data here to
update
and observable
now i display
the scene
and now we also get it mapped to the
correct position
this is pretty important if you're kind
of
[Music]
trying to move something in data space
which is usually your plot and
trying to pick something which is
usually in pixel coordinates
so it's important to have all both
of these coordinate systems working
we can also
do this whole thing
in the recipe itself
it's
not
that clean
in the moment because
you
actually need to get access to the scene
um
which you can
by getting the parent scene
but
we want to
for marquee 1.0 we want to have a
different api for that so that you can
also
register for access events and things
like that and not manipulate the scene
directly because
yeah uh recipes shouldn't really mutate
the scene as much
in that sense but
yeah let's
try to implement
this kind of
[Music]
a mouse track
to drag a point around
i already
prepared something for this because it's
a bit
um
yeah cumbersome to go through all these
events and figure out what to do one
after each other
but
yeah let me step through it so first we
get
the scene
then we do the same thing as before
with
being the mouse event
here
um
then we actually listen to this mouse
events observable as before
and
it this one has it type which is left
track start or um left click or left
drag stop
and we just care for these three right
now if if we want to have a drag
start stop action that then just moves
around the
vertex position
and
yeah so
once we start the track
we
look
if we are hovering above
um
the scatter plot here because that's the
one we want to move
um and the pick api returns the plot
you're hovering above in the current
scene
and with the index for example in a
scatter
to
tell you which scatter you're hovering
above
so then we can here
actually it's a bit more cleaner
if we just say scatter plot
in here because this also returns the
plot
um
and then we can compare the return plot
from pick
if that's the one we are interested in
and then we can set the index
of the current
vertex we want to move
yes and that's how we start our track
and then
the next event that's interesting is
that we are currently
dragging and we should only do something
if the drag index is set because we
started by picking um the right plot
and if those conditions are true
we can then actually
manipulate this vertices
array object
that is
actually being plotted
which we do here so
at the drag index
we need to
set the new position and because we want
to drag it it's
the
mouse event in the data position so in
the same coordinate space
that the plot is in
and then we
notice notify these vertices observables
and the
connection one
because they both then need to change
after we directly manipulated the array
in here
and then if we are stopping we just need
to reset the drag index because
then we are done
let's see if this works because
um
i actually changed
our one thing
that we already want to
is
that the scatter plot should come after
the line segment so that it's above
on the lines
because that makes
picking easier and we might want to make
the marker size a bit bigger
and that looks much better
and nothing happens
of course
let's see
but that brings us to debugging these
kind of problems
um
yeah let's first start by
actually seeing
the event
so we see this actually not even called
um
why is it not called
um
ah because we added to the wrong scene
i see
so
now
we should get the events
and we get the dragging
and we print a lot of stuff because i'd
edit this here
yeah so this is
one
kind of simple and complex
interaction that you could add to
recipes
you could also just have this as a
convenience function and to add this to
existing scenes
where you already know the plot types
inside
that's a bit
i'm of
taste i would maybe recommend right now
if you're in a package
to not add it to the recipe because we
want to rework the api and make it more
official how to do these kind of
interactions
[Music]
and until then
leave it out of the recipe but it can be
really nice to also just create
interactive recipes like this
um
yeah i
while we're talking about
experimental
features people have been asking for
more complex
interaction with the recipe system so
for example having and convert arguments
um
actual keyword arguments here so that
for example you could change
the algorithm
in here which is currently hard coded
which is possible right now but not
heavily um
talked about because
it's also a bit of an ad hoc api that is
not as clean as i would like it to
because
um you actually have to overload a
function like this to advertise
which keyword argument you would
actually listen to
and why it's so complicated
that's because in here
with this keyword arguments going
in here they are all observables
so
if you just always
pass them here and listen to all the
changes from everything
and the convert argument function would
be called for color change even though
nothing in here
relies on the color
and that's actually the reason why only
keyword arguments get passed to the
convert argument function
that are advertised by this used
attributes which could be multiple ones
here so you're returning a tuple
but
once you actually overload it
you can then
have a keyword argument right here
so
can we actually move this out of here
yep
it's a bit confusing with so little
space
right like this
um
then nothing would change much here um
let's
try a new example
with a new kind of graph and then
actually pass it a different
layouting algorithm
um
which takes a bit to layout or compile
and then we
get a differently layouted plot
like this and all the interactions and
everything still work of course because
all of this happens actually
earlier in the pipeline
and then if we remove this
we can see that the
layout looks different
um
yeah this is a bit
doomed for change i think once we really
start working on the recipe system
and i hope once i work more in maki that
there will be more time to overwork
things like that
there's also the other
um
a bit of experimental api
where you can return whole plot objects
from convert arguments and therefore
then actually pass
arguments
and
the way this works
is if you have your own struct like
a very simple one like here
then
you need to actually overload this a bit
funky signature because
that's what's getting passed down to the
dispatch then if you're
calling for example plot
my graph
um because
at this point we don't really know
um where this goes yet
in terms of um if it goes to a scatter
or if it goes to the graph plot thing
but then we can actually
just return a plot spec with
with the
plotting type we want to target and one
thing is here as well
it doesn't recursively apply convert
argument so if it's not already in the
right form we need to apply it manually
and but then we can pass this kind of
attribute here
on top of things so
let's just define this
my graph
let's
just use the same
graph here
and then we should see that this works
with the new
attribute
from here which could also then be
stored in this struct
to make more complex convert arguments
once
yeah but this was cooked up for algebra
of graphics ages ago
and hasn't been really maintained or
documented since then and
i think we want to make it a bit more
nicer before before we heavily advertise
it but
it will be quite similar i think the
direction um that we have some kind of
um
plot argument a plot object that you can
return that then gets plotted instead of
like the arguments and basically
skipping
parts
of the recipe steps
all right
are there any questions
so
there's this question which i think
julius probably
has a better answer to
can we return from the rectangle zoom
using the left arrow key i
i don't think so right
i tried to answer that in the in the
chat
i understood it such that i think when
you
reset the zoom right that you could do
that with the left arrow key so yeah you
can call reset limits you can hook that
up to any kind of keyboard event that
you want
but the default is ctrl left click
and
we don't really offer much of a way to
change that right now i think
because it wasn't contested
anyone so far
but yeah i think these things they
change over time a little bit like if
you add more things to the interface
then you start seeing
that you have to add more options for
people
or
move things around a little bit
um so in principle you can do it yes but
apparently we may don't make it terribly
easy to do
yeah
um then there's is there a standard
control box like in other plotting
packages with common events and
interactivity
not yet
um
but i think the widget library in
marquis is now advanced enough that we
could edit at some point as an optional
feature
i guess most of the mentioned
interactions like home zoom pen safe
fake
are implemented so it would just be a
matter of creating a button for it
ah you already answered this
um predicted date from marquee 1.0
that's a tricky one because
we have been moving that always because
yeah
the recipe
changes never really
happened because it's kind of hard to
work on such a complex
topic just on the side without having
like real time dedicated to it
i think that will be the main breaking
change for 1.0
um besides of a small few small other
braking changes but we have already
weren't too shy to
some from some time to time break a few
small things
um but if funding and everything goes
well and i will be able to work more
full-time on maki or at least half-time
um
then maybe
middle of next year or something like
that
um
it depends a bit but
yeah would be really nice to figure out
lightweight
recipes and high-level recipes that can
interact with the layout
um
can you have interactive pop-up boxes to
mutate properties of future plans
i think you kinda can do this these days
but it's definitely there's no nice api
for it um
frederick um fire actually
added
in the one of the newer releases that
you can have multiple windows so
for example if you
do something like this
um
yeah
so that's a geomarky feature
and you can open a new window a second
one
so
it would be possible to create a pop-up
window with that but you can close again
but yeah nothing
is added to this yet and i guess you
would want to also hide the decorations
and stuff like that but
yeah that's a little bit further out to
make it really nice
all right maybe we should
jump to the next part because otherwise
julius will run out to
really
beautiful app
yeah i mean
i will try to answer some more in the
chat
sure
okay what's the
uh
standing like we wanted to talk quickly
about
i think sizes and units
like five minute thing i just briefly
want to show that because it's asked
pretty often
and then yeah one more interactive app
example
okay
do this again
uh so where did i have it uh figure size
right so one question
um
that we often get
is like how to make if you if you make a
figure for publication right you usually
have some physical size you're targeting
some like i don't know i picked up
something uh like nature's full width
figure for example is
183 millimeters wide and so the question
is how do i make a
figure with maki that has that size
and what do the units even mean when you
specify a resolution of a figure and the
way it is right now so i put in the
question what units does maki use pixel
point centimeter or whatever
so
the thing is that
each back end
has different output formats right so gl
marquee you can save a bitmap like a png
with cairo marquee you can save both
pngs but also vector graphics like svgs
or pdfs
and
each of those formats has different ways
that
a dimension a physical or like a size
can be specified
and
the thing is that basically pixel
graphics so if you have like a 500 by
500 pixel sized image
that basically has no
physical size right
if you
wanted to specify a picture
for the nature forward figure of 183
millimeters and you wanted to specify it
in pixels you can't because a pixel is
just like
it's just a thing on the screen
basically
and it doesn't have a physical size
unless you have a
intermediate metric like how many pixels
per i don't know like centimeter you
have or pixels per inch or whatever so
something you see sometimes it's like a
ppi
uh thing pixels per inch or something
similar to that is dpi or dots per inch
and so those things like dots were
printed dots but sometimes people just
use it interchangeably with pixels
um so you cannot save a pixel
sized image in a physical size unless
you decide what kind of dpi or ppi
you're looking at right so
that means
you have to do it like in reverse if you
have um at least for the pixel sized
images so if you have a physical size
that you want to target
um so like
130 83 millimeters and then let's say
you say i want 10 pixels per millimeter
then you would say like times 10 that's
the amount of pixels that you have
and then the thing would be have to be
like
1830 pixels wide
um
and then you could go ahead and do like
a
figure
where you say resolution is like 1830
times whatever you want
and this if you saved a bitmap file with
gl marquee it would have exactly the
number of pixels that you want and add
your dpi or ppi
that you chose you would get the size
but for publications we often don't
specif
we don't use bitmaps so much but we try
to use vector graphics and vector
graphics don't specify their widths in
pixels because they don't have pixels
but they use
a point usually and point or like pt
is a measure that is actually
by definition usually tied to um
tied to other physical metrics like one
inch is usually 72 points at least in
the way that cairo uses it which powers
cairo marquis so that's the relevant one
for us
and one inch of course like 2.54
centimeters so that with those
if you specify a
plot in point then
it has immediately like a physical size
and
so in this case
like because machi doesn't really use
units it depends on how the numbers that
you give the figure size how they are
interpreted when outputting the stuff
right
so but if you wanted to save a vector
graphic with this width of 183
millimeters then you would say
okay how many inches are in that
millimeter size and then times 72 that
would give you the the number of points
and point is if you save a figure if you
save an image with cairo then it uses
points if you do a vector graphic so
that's the number that you want to
target so let's say we do this
um that would give us 518 point
something points
um for the width and then we'll just say
like
some height relative to that let's say
like with a ratio of two to three
and now i can make a figure with that
width and height and point
and points
and i should actually activate
chiromarky because that's that's meant
for that
so now i do this
figure and i just add these three things
to it
right
and so now you can see an image here
i'll pull up the screen a bit
um
right so this because kairomaki is
currently in in bitmap format now the
dimensions that we gave to it have been
interpreted in pixel size right so this
thing is actually 518 times 345 pixels
right and that's not a lot so you can
see it's pretty blurry
um the way you
the way you change that is by
calling activate with the type that you
want and i'll change to svg
and i also set just for
just for demonstration i set this extra
keyword points per unit and so this
means how many points is one like of
these unitless numbers interpret
when i save
so i call this and then i do the same
plot again
just
like this
and now you can see i have exactly the
same plot so if i go back and forth the
dimensions are exactly the same but this
one is a vector graphic and this one is
a is an image
and the reason why i chose
0.75 here is that it's kind of like a
web
standard that
they like whoever implemented those web
or like wrote those web standards they
chose that
by default a pixel
is related to a point by this
ratio of 0.75
so if you want in web
context if you want a vector graphic
that has the same size that the browser
chooses as a bitmap then kind of the
dimensions of the
the vector graphic have to be 0.75 that
of the pixel
graphic right so if i go back and forth
between those two you can see there's
enough space like
that's how you know that the the image
here is not not squished or anything
that's the size that the browser wants
it to take and it's the same for both
but of course the bitmap is very blurry
so if we change back to png
we can do a different keyword which is
not point per unit but pixels per unit
and the default is one
so the default is chosen such for those
two point seven five and point one and
one it's chosen this way so that in like
a pluto notebook or jupyter notebook or
whatever
by default the images will have the same
apparent size but often we like the
pixel resolution of this is not enough
for us so what we can do is we can dial
that up we can say if i specify like
a figure with a certain like number of
units in width like 518 i can just
interpret one unit as two pixels with
pigs per unit like uh equals to
falling back to german here um
right so if we do that and call this
thing same thing again
then you can see now the plot became
bigger
until basically it had to be forced
smaller by the the remaining space here
but it's also much less pixelated and we
can even dial that up further
picks per unit is four
and now i mean i don't know if you can
see the difference but like this is
pretty fine resolution
um
so that's how how you choose that so
bitmaps as i say they don't really have
a physical size the physical size of it
is kind of related to it only via web
standards or whatever
conversion you choose yourself for like
the print medium that you target if you
print at all today
say that's the last thing i want to show
if you or like those two things if you
then save a pdf i would recommend if you
if you want all
in like for example what the font size
is and what the line with this if you
want all of that to just mean point
then you just set point per unit is one
then the two are the same right and then
if you if you say this figure with this
particular resolution
like 518 and 345 you save that with as a
pdf with point per unit is one then you
will get exactly
183 millimeters in size and the font
size will be 10 points and so on
so that's how you do that yeah and
remember that it's 0.75 by default
because for interactive display
as i said
it matches pixels and
pixel pixel-based graphics and
vector-based graphics
yeah and the only other thing that's
left here still is what happens if you
don't want to size your figure by
some
external metric but you want to decide
by the content how large it should be
so we can execute this code which makes
like a
a good point so this actually
we need to make those larger
let's say we have a figure and we make
some actors and and those and give those
fixed sizes of 200 that's too big for
the figures so you can see they kind of
bleed out
like stick out at the sides there's this
function called resize to layout and
if
the content of your figure has known
sizes then it can compute what space is
needed for that and if you run the whole
thing like this then
you can see it jump back now just
because the plotting pane kind of scales
the image back but you can see that the
content now fits and the
figure has uh
how do i check that
yeah it has a size of 763 by
1011 now
while the default is something like 800
by 600
yeah that's how you get physical sizes
and i think with that i'll jump quickly
to the uh
interactive example
um because we're running kind of out of
time even though we started later
um
might over
like draw over like five minutes or so
maybe to finish that
okay so i'll close this
and that as well
and uh the file that i want to show was
like the
where was that oh yeah imageviewer
okay
um
so i'll probably have to go over this a
bit more quickly than i plan to just
because of the time
all right so the idea i'll actually
execute i think everything for once um
so you can see what we're trying to
build
uh the idea was that i i just downloaded
some json
data from from the
nasa
day of the picture of the day side
and i wanted to make like an app that
can scroll through these images and show
some statistics on them so um
the in the in the repository is already
the json file with all the info about
those images and i'll just run these
functions so you can see it
will take a small
moment until it shows
uh yeah so that's how it looks
and so you're supposed to be able to
like go through here click on next image
and then it will download that from the
internet
takes a small moment and now we have a
different image and here on the side you
have a histogram of red blue and green
channels and if i
zoom into the picture here then the
histogram updates
to only uh display the pixels that we
have selected currently in
in this area
and so yeah i want to show how you can
set up something like that
and
i think i'll probably explain it now
with the actual code that i wrote i was
planning to
to go more like step by step but i think
we don't have the time to do it quite
like that
all right
so
um
yeah and the idea is to use observables
and i think we haven't yeah we have seen
those a little bit but it can't hurt to
to see them a little bit more
um so we start by
opening uh the the metadata that that we
have from the from this json file so if
i just run this then in the
i'll close this for now
then in the wrapper you can see like
some data it has like a date it has some
explanation what the image is and it has
like a url to the image
and a title
um
so what we want to do is
we want to
use an index into this array of however
many images there are i think like
length method
data
like there are 343 images to choose from
and we want to dynamically like load
images from the web and show them in
maki and then hook up all these like
this these histogram statistics to them
and the way you do it with observables
is that you think about what how does
the information flow through this
through this app it's like a bit like
this reactive way of thinking
um
and the base thing is the index into
this
metadata array so which image you're
currently in huh it seems like uh your
screen share has frozen maybe you can
restart it
sure i can try
um
although now
the cursor blinks at least
okay
well can you see it now
uh
[Music]
yep there's quite a delay on youtube
okay
all right so hopefully it doesn't freeze
now
so okay we start with the index into the
metadata array so the the nth image that
we want to show right and we start with
one so the first one we make an
observable with one integer in it and
now we use the lift syntax
to derive other values from this value
and to derive values again from from
those intermediate values and then feed
those to plotting functions
and so the the syntax that i often use
is the macro syntax with add lift
which means that every
expression with a dollar sign in here
references an observable
a note like tells this expression that
we want to derive a value from it so my
entry the metadata entry is always the
the index
into metadata with like that comes from
this observable right so right now it's
the first index so if i run this
then my entry is now an observable of
some json object
and this first entry is this uh
yeah that's like taurus helmet
image with this particular url
and so now we can lift the next kind of
piece of data from that and we say
our image data is
we lift from the entry and for for the
entry we call e this like an anonymous
function uh syntax and julia for those
who haven't seen it
so for an entry e we pick the field e
url which is then this here
ipod nasa.gov whatever like a jpeg file
and we pack that into the function load
image
and load image just takes the url and
uses this just like a special syntax
tool to write it more nicely in a
sequential fashion it uses http to get
the url
extracts the body from that object puts
that into an i o buffer which then can
be passed to the load function which
extracts the image
so and the whole thing is
memoized so that for the same url we
only load the image once that's what
this is doing
right so
if i execute this then it will load an
image from the internet and put that
into this image thing and we can see now
that the
the type of this inside the observable
is now a matrix of rgbs
so an image basically
um
right so what can we do now with this
image we can of course try to plot it
and the function for that is in marquee
is usually the image function
aptly named
um so yeah what we can do is like we
make
i can just make a figure here
and add an image plot to it at position
one one as we saw before
i actually don't pass the image
in as is because and that's like a
peculiarity in
in maki or in julia maybe um
because the storage of an image is
usually that the first dimension refers
to the rose and
the
second dimension refers to the columns
but
if you plot an image in machi it
determines that the first dimension is x
and the second is y so that's kind of
flipped from how you normally think
about it
so to plot it here i actually flip it
back with this transpose operator
and i also
reverse the
the direction of the y-axis and that's
usually how you plot images
the y-axis kind of counts down pixels
and the x-axis
comes over to the right
and in this case i set the aspect of the
axis to data aspect so the image isn't
skewed
you can look at this here so that's how
it looks like if we don't set the aspect
to that x aspect as uh
what was it i think nothing
yeah if we don't set that then it's
squished right so x don't aspect
this data aspect
then we get this nicer nicer view
um
then we can hide the decorations of this
axis because we don't really need like
the pixel numbers here
right so we already have the image
and the interesting thing is that
the like plotting
a new
image should already work
we had some trouble with it before like
in this streaming scenario because i
think
it just taxes my my gpu in a different
way but i'll try it here
oh yeah it actually worked so
uh if i change the index observable to
two
now the thing runs in sequence right it
downloads the next end or loads the next
entry from the metadata within x2 then
it loads the image for that url in that
entry and then automatically because we
passed this observable to image it
automatically changes the image here
the only thing that didn't change are
the limits of the access um which you
kind of have to do yourself but we will
see that in a bit i can control click to
reset that though so this is how it
would ideally look
so we can do the same with like three
now it actually has to download it from
the internet yeah and there's the new
image
and right
and as you can see the title i also
lifted from the entry right so the title
also changes to be correct um and i did
that with the add lift syntax and it
just took the title from the from the
given entry
so that's nice like we only have to
change this one number and then the
graphic already changes
um
which is
usually a really nice way to specify
the flow of your logic
okay so now the idea was to display like
a histogram a color histogram on the
side so what we can do for that is we
make another axis
at
row one column two there it is
and now we think about
how this histogram should be computed
and my idea was that
um
that i want to actually incorporate the
limits of the axis to decide which
pixels to to bin and so
i define
uh first like an observable that can
hold any data type that's just like a
convenience thing now because i don't
know what the exact type of a subset of
this pixel stuff is so any just
means i can worry about that later
i i define this observable it's empty
there's nothing in it and now i say
whenever image or the limits of the xs
change i want to change something about
this observable and what i do is i look
at the
the axis limits i look at like from x to
y
from low x to high x from low y to high
y then i clamp
those values which will be floating
points if i zoom in because like the x's
can have arbitrary limits
i clamp that to integers because i want
to integ index into the image right
and so i determine what x low x high y
low and y high are in terms of image of
the image
and then
as i said to you like that the data is
actually plotted in reverse
on the on the um screen here so it's a
bit weird that i index with y first but
that's just how it is and then i i take
a view of the image data at the limits
that i have and put that into the subset
observable and this will now whenever
these two values change
the subset will hold a view of the of
the image
and then because i told you before right
if um
the axis limits they don't change by
default if you change something about
the plots so because the histogram will
have different
numbers of bins um
i will reset the axis that holds this
this thing later
so we don't have a histogram yet but
this like presented in advance
so if i call this
and then
nothing has happened so far so the
subset
is still not assigned there is nothing
in it but if i notify the image
observable which just means like call
its listeners then this function will be
fire like it will fire
and now subset will contain
a view of this rgb thing so this is like
a subset of whatever of this image is
currently in view
and with this we can continue further
because like that's the subset of our
image
and now i define the three histograms
and here we can see three hist calls
that's the plotting command for this
and to that we want to pass a vector of
numbers right that can be binned and you
can see here three times a real similar
syntax to do that which is add lift
then i refer to the subset observable
and once i take all the red
values once i take all the green values
and ones all the blue
and i make those into a vector as well
because histogram doesn't expect 2d data
for for what i want to do but 1d data
and i also set the bins to go from
from 0 to 1 and 256 steps
and the first one gets a red the second
one green and the third one a blue color
with some
transparency applied and so if i do that
now
that's the red one that's the green one
that's the blue one
then i can also make this a bit nicer i
can say i want the lower y limits to to
start at zero because there can be
nothing below
like this then i can
set the x limits to go from one zero to
one because i already defined that they
can't go
outside of that through the bins here
right
from zero to one um right so that's
already looking good
and now about the buttons how we can
actually
uh yeah make some buttons to to go
through the images
by the way now already the the zooming
function should work because
here right the x that final limits
observable
if i now zoom into this thing then you
can see that the histogram changes and
if i zoom into it further
it changes again and i think yeah i can
also do that like interactively
like this
which is kind of nice
um at least i think so
okay so
now let's get to the buttons um
right we want to have two buttons below
this image one with like previous and
one with next
and we'll just make a nested grid layout
to hold them
which is like the easiest if you have a
sub container then you just make a new
grid layout so a grid layout at
row 2 column 1 that is right below
that will be below this this plot on the
left
so if i do this now the same thing
happened as before right because there's
nothing in this in this great layout the
row is pretty big but this will change
now that i add the button to it so i add
a button at
i don't know why i started with next but
it doesn't matter
okay so one button next
that's here now
and the next one will be
uh
yeah that's the previous button
okay
and then the idea was uh
that whenever i click at the button
um i just change the index observable
that i showed you in the beginning
right because the index controls all the
rest of the stuff in the plot so then i
wrote the small like helper function
which is supposed to offset the index
and i pass like a button to it as well
called b because i want to change the
label so the idea is just i store what
label it had
then i change that to loading i modify
the index observable
and i keep that in range from one to
length of the metadata because otherwise
i could fall off the of the edge
and then
uh
index out of bounds
and then i also do what i showed before
right i reset the limits on on both axes
because those values will have changed
um
i guess i don't even need to do access
to because it's already handled by this
function here
right i can actually i think remove that
okay so the offset index function i i do
that now and then now i assign that to
happen whenever i click those buttons so
there's the
clicks
attribute which just counts up whenever
you click the button so when you listen
to that like we don't actually need to
use the number that comes out of this
but we can just call our function
and we have this async syntax because in
julia
like we don't want the whole thing to
hang while it downloads a new picture
right so that's supposed to happen in
like a thread or like a task or like
um so
now i assign that on the first button
this should happen and here also the
second one
and you can see on the first one i i
offset by one so it goes up and on the
other one i
offset down
so and now it should work so when we
press
next
it loads the image and there's the image
and the histogram changed and the image
changed i can zoom in can look at those
reds here oh it has a lot of
red
unsurprisingly
um
right
and you can go further next image
and so on and if we looked at like
for example we can look at on index
uh
just to show you again what happens so
on index 2i
that show
just i
uh we can just see that whenever we
press a button the index goes up
so i six
is five
i have six
now it loads an image again i7 and so on
so yeah that's how
and not a lot of
code you can
specify a dynamic app um
that reacts to the data that you change
and
yeah i think you can
go with your own creativity and think of
things that you could you could do with
this and of course these are all like
interactive like i can zoom around here
if i want
um
yeah as i showed you before
right i think that's pretty much it
and we are also kind of out of time so
yeah simon i'll
ask you to come back we can answer like
last questions if there's
there's more stuff
yeah
um thank you
that's a really cool app
that seems to be the main comments
yeah that's uh yeah thank you
what's my monospaced font oh it's uh
it's this apple thing it's uh sf mono
important questions first
i think we missed some questions in the
very beginning but i'm not even sure if
the context was right anymore and
and
i was like in a tunnel i didn't see
anything i didn't see any questions
so i would suggest to just ask this
question on discord discourse or slack
um preferably
um
yeah
yeah probably this yeah yeah go to our
discourse
through the new one i think everybody
can just go there right yeah there are
already quite a few people uh that join
yeah
okay cool yeah just ask them there
because i have to go to a birthday party
and can't
can't answer now
but i'll i'll come back to those later
yeah and yeah someone asked like the
buttons don't seem to be from a specific
toolkit no all hand coded by yours truly
that's insane task of reinventing all
standard gui kit things but yeah
i did that at least for some widgets
we'll have to see in the future if we
can put pull in some other like more
established gui kits because
like it's really insane to
implement
really good text handling and i think if
we don't have to we don't want to
yeah
i think there's already some prototypes
for gtk and qg integration but it's not
maintained
but
maybe in the future um
there could be a project to actually
um improve that by by a lot
right
someone asked does maki have a way to
visualize tabular data like vs code
display
uh
not really
but i mean
you can kind of abuse i can quickly show
that
and abuse the grit ladder yeah i'm
always i always like setting up grid
layouts
you can do like uh like this
uh whoops
trying to go too fast
uh
let's say like five rows and
i definitely also remember some
discourse threat where someone tried
that i don't know if that ended up in a
package or just in a
script
yeah yeah i mean i did i did stuff like
that before so
um
so you can i think this should work yeah
there's a table
so if you do now like uh
resize to layout on that
that's actually what it's handy for
right because then yeah that's your
table
and you could also do stuff like um
font is
like i
equals one and then it's like
maki
has bold i think and otherwise it's just
okay yes
should hopefully work yeah now the first
line is bold i mean
font size is 30 or whatever
so yeah you could you can so if you have
a plot and it has to have a uh whoops
it has to have a table next to it you
can definitely do it with like grid
layouts
okay
yeah
all right i think we just terminate
punctually
amazing
okay well we needed less time because we
started later but that's fine
um
yeah
cool
cool
yeah we'll be happy to see new people in
the this course and asking questions
discord discord
this chord is the chat app this course
is the the general julia forum both are
cool go to both
exactly
all right cool
yeah thanks everyone and see you around
at troyakon
yeah
all right have a great evening everybody
or morning if you are on the other side
of the earth
it's on cool
bye